vamos a resolver otro de estos
entretenidos problemas de edad y el
siguiente problema dice esto vicente
tiene cuatro veces la edad de álex hace
doce años
vicente tenía siete veces la edad de
álex que da tiene álex actualmente y
bueno estaría muy bien que tú intentará
resolver lo primero por ti mismo sin ver
el vídeo porque a continuación voy a dar
la solución entonces lo primero que voy
a hacer es preguntarme que quiero y lo
que quiero es la edad de álex
actualmente por lo tanto vamos a definir
con una cierta variable la edad de álex
voy a suponer b&b es la edad de álex
actualmente y justo ahora
entonces se ve la edad de álex justo
ahora y voy a hacer esto con la mayor
formalidad posible si yo tuviera un
problema si en un examen haría justo
esto lo primero que haría es una tablet
que tabla primero me voy a fijar en la
edad de álex y en la de vicente así que
deja de poner aquí álex y acá abajo
vicente vicente muy bien y hay dos
fechas importantes en este problema que
fechas bueno la primera es lo que pasa
justo ahora es decir hoy vamos a ponerle
aquí lo que pasa hoy o lo que pasa
actualmente lo que pasa hoy y la otra
fecha importante es lo que pasó hace 12
años hace 12 años que fue lo que pasó
bueno vamos a fijarnos primero en la
edad que tiene alex actualmente álex
actualmente pues tiene ve años es justo
como habíamos definido a ver
álex actualmente tiene ve años y que
pasaba con álex hace 12 años
bueno pues hace 12 años álex tenía pues
la edad que tiene actualmente menos
hace años es decir ve - 12 muy bien ya
sabemos perfectamente qué onda con álex
al menos en variables vamos a fijarnos
ahora en vicente vicente qué edad tiene
actualmente bueno fíjate en esta oración
aquí está lo importante de este problema
vicente tiene cuatro veces la edad de
álex actualmente el vicente tiene cuatro
veces la edad de álex es decir que si
álex tiene b años vicente tiene cuatro
veces ven cuatro veces su edad muy bien
y queda tenían vicente hace doce años
pues suena muy lógico vicente tenía la
edad que tiene ahorita menos doce años
exactamente igual que lo que le pasó a
álex entonces 4 menos 12 muy bien hasta
aquí espero que vayamos todo en orden
porque viene el paso más importante
vamos a fijarnos el clic dice esta
oración hace 12 años
vicente tenía pues lo que sabemos es 4
menos 12 pero además nos dicen que desde
otra perspectiva
vicente tenían
siete veces la edad que tenía álex hace
doce años es decir siete veces esta edad
y por lo tanto si yo multiplico esta
edad por siete podemos llegar a una
ecuación aquí está lo importante de este
problema hace 12 años vicente tenía
siete veces la edad de álex es decir que
si vicente hace 12 años tenía 49 menos
12 esto tiene que ser igual a la edad de
álex que tenía hace 12 años por 7 es
decir 7 por b menos 12 vamos a
escribirlo aquí 7 que multiplica a b
menos 12 es decir la edad que tenía álex
hace 12 años multiplicada por 7 tiene
que ser igual a la edad que tenía
vicente hace 12 años es decir 4 menos 12
y ya tengo una ecuación con solamente
una incógnita por lo tanto de equipo
despejar a b y lo primero que voy a
hacer es distribuir la multiplicación
por este 7 este 7 multiplicada todo lo
que está dentro del paréntesis es decir
7 multiplica bien y 7 multiplica a menos
12 7 por ver es 7 pm y 7 por menos 12 es
menos 84
7 pm 84 esto es igual a 4 b menos 24 pm
12 muy bien y bueno como quiero a las
ves positivas lo que voy a hacer es
dejar todo lo que tenga que ver con ven
de este lado de la ecuación del lado
izquierdo y para esto lo que voy a hacer
es restar 4 b de ambos lados de la
ecuación es decir menos 420 menos 420 y
entonces que me queda bueno primero
menos 4 b y 4 bert se cancelan 4 b menos
420 se van y solamente me quedan menos
12 y del lado izquierdo me queda 7 b
menos 420 estos 3 b
3b - 84 muy bien y ahora lo que voy a
hacer es sumar 84 de ambos lados de la
ecuación para que me quede 3 veces
solamente de un lado de la ecuación así
que voy a sumar 84 del lado izquierdo
84 del lado derecho estos dos se van de
lado izquierdo solamente me queda 3 bien
perfecto mientras que el lado derecho
que me va a quedar es 84 menos 12 84
menos 12 es
72 perfecto 72 3b es igual a 72 y ahora
voy a dividir ambos lados de la ecuación
entre 3 de tal manera que 3 y 3 se van y
solamente me queda b b es igual a 72
entre 3 que según yo bueno no soy
calculadora humana pero creo que es 24
es más vamos a corroborar los vamos a
ver si es 24 72 entre 33 cabe dos veces
en 72 por 3-6 7-6 es 1 y bajó el 2 y
después dice 4 perfecto 4 x 3 es 12
entonces ven vale 24 y ya está ya tengo
lo que yo quería la edad de alex alex
tiene 24 años en la actualidad en la
actualidad alex tiene 24 años muy bien
pero ahora vamos a completar la tabla
vicente tenía cuatro veces la edad de
álex actualmente y 4 por 24 es 96 es
decir que vicente actualmente tiene 96
años
es decir que podría ser su abuelo o tal
vez alguna de las personas de la tercera
edad con los que juega ajedrez 12 y
bueno lo que sé es que vicente hace 12
años hace 12 años vicente tiene 84 años
96 - 284 hace 12 años vicente tenía
siete veces la edad de alex alex hace 12
años tenía 12 años porque 24 - 12 es 12
y 12 por 7 es 84 por lo tanto concuerda
todo